[Music]
hello there chapter 4's final season is
here the last resort a season with a
Vampire as the main antagonist who can
travel through time this update brings a
host of new map changes a ton of
questionable law for the story lovers
out there like you and I and we'll break
it all down together first take my
Creator code in the face here you go I'm
adamaru let's do this
the new season has three major map
updates with lonely Labs the area around
Rowdy acres and the Citadel all going
away replaced with sanguine sweets
Relentless Retreat and eclipsed estate
but the changes begin before that like
in the pre-match lobby the view of our
island is now obscured by this land mass
upon it is a sculpture just like those
found in the new pois so we can safely
say that the eclipse brought that here
with kado the big bad guy kaido Thorne
is found in eclipsed estate a POI that
has obliterated The Citadel the place we
believe gen now left a snapshot to rule
over his kingdom it's now gone forever
and it pains me to say this but the rift
gate has also been removed Rift Warden
stellen's attempt to open a door to
other worlds ended in disaster and now
it's forgotten rip storyline from
chapter 4 season 1. I think it's fair to
say this POI is superior here it's
possible to locate one of kado's bolts
and a chance to pick up a single item
from his collection and from our
fortnite history on the way into his
room keep an eye on the walkway it's
possible to see other items he's taken
over time which includes recent things
like the statues that guard the old
Citadel and those found at brutal
Bastion but it's the other side of the
room that has the wow factor is this the
Hand of Midas it's a very similar pose
to his old promo shots what could this
mean well it could mean two things one
it's a sculpture adorned in gold which
makes a lot of sense all this is midas's
real hand and I don't think fortnite
would go that [__] or would they if a
new miter skin releases with only one
hand we know why next to the oversized
Greco-Roman Shield thingy is another
puzzling artifact a piece of stone with
markings upon it I first thought these
were the same as those seen in chapter
3. if you can remember that far back
each of the seven had their own column
of rock to represent them a few of these
definitely line up but not all so then I
went all the way back to chapter 1
season 7 and The Ice King's Castle in
there was a circular table just like
this picture with many symbols I don't
have a good enough shot to look at these
but I was wondering if this ties back to
that event and then according to Lika
Fort Tori this item is named the lupus
calendar so it's important but I have no
idea how can anyone help me out here at
these new locations is a familiar
pattern on many doors yes it's the
Crescent shape for the season but it's
also a shape we found on the zero points
Vault two seasons ago once again proving
the story is far bigger than that one
orb of power which is quite a good thing
because the zero point remains a rusted
Ball Bearing in the middle of the map
right now for a second season anyway
back to this location before we move on
there's another Vault down here we can't
open yet and of course we have to check
what's behind it are you ready
absolutely nothing anti-climax are what
there are stairs behind here so maybe in
a future update we will see what is down
these stairs maybe it's the room from
the trailer I next visited the sleeping
zero point and the apparatus and to my
surprise it was still there yet not
working in fact it's really glitchy
right now with floating pedestals and
totally breakable footings I'm sure this
will be updated but right now you can
hide underneath the apparatus
the SEC new POI has replaced the frosty
lonely Labs with sunny sanguine Suites a
hotel no less and this hotel is fully
high class luxurious pools bar and
dining and of course another Vault to
ransack and check out the artwork here
it is very post-modern with Cubist
sensibilities don't you think and is
that Sloan how many people can rock a
yellow pair of glasses and still look
good doing it in fact we should have an
artwork section right now because it's
possible to find many art referencing
pieces of fortnite lore like that time
we flipped an island
and remember when tons of Cubes sprouted
out of the ground
good memories and is this lady from the
Chrome season and of course the time the
island flew in the air thanks to Kevin
the cube
[Music]
oh good memories bro but there's one
picture which is so important to the law
I have to show you it now take a look at
this the Mona Lisa has never looked so
good
foreign
the final new POI introduced this season
replaces the lower left corner of the
island and I don't think anyone ever
actually went down there and it's now a
rehab center for retired Fortnight Pros
Relentless Retreat is a perfect Crescent
shape and my OCD appreciates that thank
you fortnite devs Elsewhere on the
island there are updates you may have
missed like this tiny change thanks to a
misplaced Marvel document last season
the community thought a desk with a
Stark Industries folder on it was a sign
that Iron Man was returning to the story
well the fortnite devs in charge of that
made sure there was no more talk of it
and completely removed that desk and its
contents the table has now been updated
no more Marvel elsewhere you've probably
noticed the huge radio towers that give
the island the best Wi-Fi and Cellular
Connection in history these things are
in fact storm forecast towers as when
Ikea applied from a nearby NPC will
highlight the next safe Zone from the
storm pretty useful and finally over to
the barn at frenzy Fields this is the
home of the The Heist gang it's only
quite humble right now but I'm sure as
we gather more loot things will upgrade
here and I absolutely need to know what
this Crystal thing here is whatever it
is I like to look at it this is also
where we meet Nolan Chance The
Mastermind behind the heists against
Kato Thorne and a little law can be
found here too it's revealed that Sloan
is the one who put our name forward to
join this crack team which gets me
wondering why so here's my take on what
happened this season and how it links to
last season
the wild season showed us a civilization
who were waiting for the Eclipse which
brings kadathon to their Homeland this
happened so regularly that they built
monuments to celebrate this Godlike
being and also a telescope that could
plot the next eclipse and therefore tell
us when their God is returning with this
information in mind Sloan began to plan
and we've already seen her goal in the
trailer kaino Thorne can time travel he
went back to oral's release date to take
a souvenir for himself and his
collection my bet is that Sloan intends
to steal or maybe simply use that time
travel vehicle to go back and change
something we've lived through before it
could be the io fighting for the island
it could be the Marvel event it could be
hiring agent Jones or it could be to go
back and fix all the plot issues
that chair is the key to our future and
our past did an Optimus Prime say
something similar to that
the key to your future lies in the past
our vampiric enemy is also shown to have
a Jonesy snapshot in jail once we find
him we'll know more and once fought
nightmares arrives I really think things
will get good for now get to know the
island and those vaults as the biggest
heist in history is coming soon I'm Adam
you're awesome I'll see you next time
[Music]
someone try and take him Outdoors to see
what type of vampire he is I'm hoping
he's a glittery one like the ones in
Twilight
beautiful
[Music]